kalyn's I you have now been serving as
director than the bell Institute and as
such also as permanent secretary for the
Nobel Committee for about 20 years how
will you characterize this year's
decision by the Nobel Committee I would
characterize it as an important decision
we were finally able to deal with the
issue of women wore security and women's
rights and and we were happy to have
three laureates to make it clear that
this is an issue that concerns almost
the entire world what basic issues had
been most central for the committee in
his deliberation for the two for this
year's price well the committee believes
that there are many different roles to
peace and therefore there are many
different kinds of laureates but we have
wanted or the committee has wanted to
focus on on the role of women and the
time came this year I mean this issue
has been of concern to the UN Security
Council it has been addressed by many
governments around the world because we
see that in wars women are the victims
and rape of course is one sign of this I
mean in the former Yugoslavia indar food
in Congo so we want to focus on the
situation of women in war and also point
to the way out the way out is democracy
full rights for women and the full
participation of women also in the
making of peace very few women are
involved in peacemaking and many more
should become involved are you to take
on whims that all three piece by laura's
will come to oslo in december well we
certainly hope so that we have not been
able to be in contact with all three of
them so we'll see but this is this is
what we hope in 1976 the Peace Prize for
1976 but in 1977 we're given to the
northern island p
women Betty Williams and more red
Corrigan could this yes decision be
compared to the one in 1976 I think this
year's price is more global I mean the
one you're referring to deftly northern
Island an issue which of course was very
important but we had to return to it
some decades later now we are referring
to the situation of women in general all
around the world but also in particular
parts I mean where there is war and
where the rights of women have not been
fully respected and we see this in
Africa and we certainly see this in the
Arab world and also in many other parts
of you for many years the Nobel Peace
Prize has more or less been a human
rights price how will you catalog this
year's price well it has something to do
with human rights absolutely i mean
women's rights are human rights and it's
also dealing with democracy but there is
also another aspect to this and and and
this is the situation of women in warp
so there is a humanitarian aspect or
there's even a new category which is
being created this year the committee
had more than 250 nominees and does that
mean that the nobel peace prize is
getting more and more popular and more
and more coveted absolutely we see that
the focus on the nobel peace prize is
growing all the time I've been here for
21 years and and even in this limited
period there's been a dramatic rise and
of course nothing compared to last year
i think the the price Tulio shall bow in
2010 I mean you used it was received
with a great deal of understanding and
sympathy and the coverage was unheard of
I mean all the leading newspapers all
the leading journals in the world they
cover this in great detail and almost
all of them praised in a belkin it did
so I think this may have been the
highlight in our entire history and if
we take the whole history of the Nobel p
price which is the most popular the most
the best decision by there by the
committee do you think well this is an
individual matter I have my opinions and
the committee members may have their
opinions but I mean personally in our
110 year history I think I would rank
the prices to a Calvinist yet ski Andrei
Sakharov and to Leo Shabo last year very
very high up possibly at the very top
early next year you will be 67 years old
would you then retire and write the book
over your time in the secretary of the
Nobel Committee or will you stay on
until you are 70 I have to retire by 70
I have not made up my mind exactly when
I will retire but I will stay for next
year but when I retire I will write two
books i will write one book about my
personal experience I mean all the
laureates I met and all the funny
stories which I can tell about virtually
all of these laureates and then i will
write more traditional history book
about the entire history of the price
pointing to what are the important
themes and dimensions in this every year
there is also coming up some critical
voices and somebody say this year that
the committee's work is too closed too
mysterious would it be more and more
open for theatre in the coming year well
we tried to be as open as possible but
there are statutes and these Nobel
statutes which apply to all the Nobel
prizes they say that our books our files
have to be closed for 50 years I mean as
a professor of history and I think this
is this is too much because we have
worked with governments to open them up
and I think we should open up we have
suggested that maybe 30 years would be
better but there is no support from the
other Nobel committees on this point
some critical voices also say that the
committee should be should have foreign
members not only
bizarre from from Norway what is your
opinion there are certainly very good
arguments in favor of bringing in
foreigners there I mean Norwegians are
they are fewer than one tenth of one
percent of the world's population so
there are many brilliant people out
there in the world the the problem with
their foreign committee is that it's
very difficult to bring these
distinguished individuals to the
meetings in Oslo I mean there are many
other piece prices in the world I talked
with them they have very prominent
international members but they don't
succeed in bringing them to the meetings
and you can imagine I mean if for
instance Kofi Annan then became a member
of the Nobel Committee and he would only
come to the final meeting no this would
not do us much good because there is a
process we work on this for almost a
full year and you have to be included
for the entire time but if foreigners
can can do this then a few foreign names
would be fine have you today been in
contact with one two or all three Peace
Prize laureates unfortunately telephone
connections are they work in mysterious
ways in certain parts of the world so we
have only succeeded in being in contact
with the laymil of always secretary
that's as far as we came Thank You guy
lender stop thank you
you